hi there today we'll look at deep
residual learning for image recognition
by climbing ha jung-woo chun Xiao Qing
run and Jian soon so this you know it
this is an old paper it is from 2015 but
I thought we'd still look at it because
this not only is it one of the most
influential papers in modern deep
learning it is also a very well written
paper and I like it was yesterday when
this came out this was like a bomb so
around that time this this meme was
going around I was winning imagenet but
then someone made a deeper net this this
was a this was at the time when after
Alex net people were trying to build
bigger and bigger networks and every
time someone managed to build a bigger
Network the accuracy on image net data
set would increase pretty much in
lockstep with how much bigger the
network was but people got to the limit
of building big networks and then this
paper drops and changed everything and
now residual connections are everywhere
not only in image recognition they are
in transformers they are in you know
whatever wherever you go you'll probably
find some residual connections somewhere
in there so yeah let's let's look at
this paper and let's revisit what kind
of problems people have then and how
they solved it so here they go directly
into into this problem of deep neural
networks and the problem that people had
was they knew that if you can increase
the if you can increase the depth of a
neural network you can make it perform
better you can make it generalize better
you can reach lower training loss but
optimizing it was hard specifically this
was a phenomenon
people observed if you have a 20 layer
neural network you could train it and
you know there is this learning rate
drop people have had already figured out
that you need to drop drop the learning
rate and it would reach a certain level
and here this would be the test error
over here
however if after a certain point if they
increase the depth even more the
training error would actually go up
again and so with the test error and
this is not a problem of overfitting
because overfitting would be when the
training error is lower or as low and
then the test error went up so this is
the first thing this is not a phenomenon
of overfitting of too many parameters so
why can't we train bigger layers
networks until that time have very much
followed kind of the original network
design that was envisioned by sort of
people like Jung Lacan and also with
Alex net and the most popular ones were
these vgg nets and they were very much
of the philosophy that you'd have like
some you have the image here and you
input that into into convolutional
layers which first would kind of keep a
big resolution but would increase the
channel size by you know some amount and
then you would sort of downscale the
image as you increase the number of
filters so you would stack more and more
filters and draw more filters you would
stack more and more filters while down
scaling the resolution of the image the
reasoning was that if you do image
classification right then you know we're
on this we're on this maybe you want to
classify this into a Lego tower or
whatever that is it's not that important
where it is so on the lower levels you
would want to parse out like very low
layer features like edges and so on and
these are still important where they are
right the fact that here is an edge
here's an edge here's an edge but then
as you go higher up
and go to more and more abstracted
features and we already knew that these
neural network they tend to learn more
and more abstract features as you go up
the layers the hypothesis was that the
exact localization of these abstract
features would be less and less
important so if there is if you
recognize that there is a rectangle it's
not that important where it is just that
it's somewhere there and maybe where it
is in relation to the other so if you
have if you recognize I want to
recognize a car the lower layers would
recognize the fact that there are edges
and then the intermediate layers would
recognize the geometric shapes of maybe
here the wheels and these parties but
it's not that important where exactly
they are and then the higher layers
would learn to combine the individual
parts to each other and again it becomes
less and less important where these
things are and more and more important
that you build more expressive features
so people would downscale the resolution
upscale the number of filters now that's
a good heuristic but this is this was
basically the architecture of these
networks and we would question why would
if we increase the number of layers so
if we instead of one here we have two of
these layers right we simply have two of
these layers and here we have two of
these layers why does it get worse
especially this paper here makes an
interesting observation so it is not
Coast caused by overfitting and adding
more layers leads to a higher training
error the degradation indicates that is
not all systems are similarly easy to
optimize let us consider a shallower
architecture and it's deeper
counterparts that adds more layers onto
it there exists a solution by
construction to the deeper model the
added layers are identity mapping and
the other layers are copied from the
learned shallower model so it's pretty
easy if you have a shallow model like
five layers
that learns a particular function I can
pretty easily prove that there is a deep
model that learns the same function by
simply copying over these five layers
and having these here learn the identity
function okay so if we are able to learn
this we should be able to train this
network to at least the same accuracy
that's what this paper argues because it
can you know these layers can simply
learn the identity function so it must
have something to do with the easiness
of optimizing these deep architectures
not with overfitting and this is I think
if you read the entire text here it's
very very clear if you read it they lead
you through this reasoning saying that
look all these layers have to do is
learn the identity function and then we
could at least get the same accuracy so
so what why don't they learn the
identity function well because we
initialize most weights you know towards
zero
we initialize them randomly but mostly
we initialize them around zero our
initialization procedure usually sample
from some Gaussian with some kind of a
standard deviation but around the mean
of zero and also if we use things like
weight decay l2 regularization all of
these things they do they bias the
weights towards zero so if there is any
natural thing that these networks are
good at is they learn the zero function
really well learning the identity
function is as difficult as learning any
other function identity function in the
convolutional filter is actually pretty
difficult to learn because you know if I
have a my if I have my three by three
filter where is my no no this ah I have
my three by three filter the identity
function is it like a one here and zeros
everywhere else that's the that that
would be one of the things it's not that
easy you need need to learn nine weights
in the correct way so this paper says
can we do something
to make the default function of the
network not be the zero function or
whatever the randomly initialized
function can we make the default
function the one function can we make
the default function the identity
function and that brings you to residual
connection so instead of learning to
transform X via a neural network into X
which is the identity function why don't
we have X stay X and then learn whatever
we need to change okay so if let's call
that tilde if the assumption is that
it's a good default to not change much
so this is almost the same as this we
might make this build this directly into
the architecture the fact that these two
are equal plus plus some deviation that
is learned right here and the hypothesis
is that especially the deeper you go if
you go very deep
each function here will actually learn
not that much it will learn to basically
change the signal a little bit but
mostly it will learn the identity
function if it behaves well and
therefore it might be you know
reasonable to build this into the
architecture and of course this has
turned out to be very accurate it has
actually been reasonable to build this
into the architecture so that's what
they proposed right here so instead of
just having weight layers one after
another what they propose is to have
these steep connections in here so these
Skip connections they will instead of
learning the function they call this
entire function H of X which might be
very complicated they learn the function
whatever F and F is whatever you need to
change about X you see at the end you
add X to it so these weight layers here
they simply learn whatever makes this
next this output different from this
input and learning differences now you
have the desire
because what do we know about weight
layers from before well they tend
towards the zero function right if we
use weight decay or generally how we
initialize them they tend towards the
zero function well if F tends towards
the zero function then H becomes the
identity function so the default
function of this network is the identity
function and whenever we learn something
we learn how to deviate from the
identity function and that is that is a
much better default function now it's
not entirely true that the default
function is the identity function you
see that here for example there's after
the Skip connection there is actually a
so there's still it's still a
nonlinear function in total the network
in total but the default for the
individual blocks here is the identity
okay now if you chain these blocks you
get a residual network and that's what
they proposed right here so on the left
you see this original vgg architecture
like we described it so you can see you
have an image which has four channels
and you first up it to 64 channels and
you keep the resolution and then you max
pool which halves the resolution but you
go up with the filters to 128 you max
pool again go up with the filters and so
on now this has even though it doesn't
look like it this has a lot of
parameters and it needs a lot of
computations it has nineteen point six
billion floating-point operation for a
forward pass
in contrast the networks were going to
build here the residual networks have
3.6 billion
flops so they are much much less in
terms of complexity than the old vgg
networks while still being much deeper
okay the hypothesis is the deeper the
better and as a trade-off per layer you
don't actually need to have that many
parameters because you don't learn that
much per layer but the succession of
layers gains you much more than simply
having
massive layers you can see at the same
size of resolution here you the the
resonance can get away with much less
amounts of filters and that's why they
are less they are of less size so this
is the comparison to VDD 19 now they do
build this 34 layer network which they
call plain and you can see it is simply
a 34 layer network with no pooling right
here and here instead of pooling they do
a stride to convolution which has also
become this has become kind of more
standard than doing max or average
pooling to downscale to do simply stride
- convolution so this paper has actually
set the standards for a lot of things in
modern deep learning so our goal is to
going to be to compare first of all the
vgg 19 to the 34 layer plane to show
that you will lose performance when you
simply up the number of layers but then
when you introduce the residual
connections as you can see right here so
there is always this jumping connection
right here so along these jumping
connections the signal can travel as the
identity function what we're going to
see is that if we go from plane to
residual introducing no extra parameters
just these skipped connections will
change everything will make this network
all of a sudden trainable and make the
deeper networks the better networks okay
the only little caveat here is of course
in order to build a residual connection
the output has to be of the same size as
the input because you need to add the
input to the output and this here for
example is not given so here you can see
this signal after this layer is going to
be half as big because it's a stride to
convolution so the output right here is
only half the size but it is it is twice
the number of filters you can see right
here this has 64 filters and here we go
to 128 filters that's why this
connection right here
has parameters in order to simply expand
the number of filters these are is 1x1
convolutions that simply up that simply
projected 64 filters to 128 filters
however this doesn't introduce too many
parameters because it's only one by one
in fact here the 34 parameters residual
network no I'm wrong um you have
different options so the world has ended
up at the option of doing one by one
convolutions but in this paper they
still they still explore three different
options and I guess here in this
particular experiment they option a is
simply to zero pad so to leave the first
64 channels but to simply append 128 0
padded filters there or channels option
B is the one by one convolution and
option C is actually that all of these
connections right here also have the one
by one convolutions which introduces
extra parameters and they they realize
that option C isn't improving over
option B substantially and in fact is
only improving marginally and they say
okay that's probably just because we
have more parameters so ultimately they
went with option B and I think that's
what the world does right now I also I
when I read this first I particularly
enjoyed this paragraph right here let's
read it together
our implementation for image net falls
to practice in da da da da da
the image is resized with shorter
randomly sampled in this for scale
augmentation 8 this crop is randomly
sampled from the image or its horizontal
flip with the per pixel as being
subtracted the standard color
augmentation is used we adopt a batch
normalization right after each
convolution before activation we this an
age-old discussion was born when to use
batch normalization before comment
before the activation or after the
activation I still I think people are
still fighting over this today we
initialize
weights as in 13 and train all plain
residual Nets from scratch use SGD de
yada yada the learning rate starts from
this is divided by then so here in this
pair heaven in this paragraph they
detail basically all the training
procedure and all the tricks that they
use that I remember specifically that
you know I read all of this which was
the idea and I could follow like oh this
is super well explained this is so cool
and so on and then I expect basically an
implementation of that and then there's
one single paragraph with like 20 line
saying oh and by the way we use these 50
tricks from these other papers and yeah
that's when it I guess you know it was
already happening you needed to do all
the modern tricks in order to really
reach the top accuracies but you know in
hindsight we know it wasn't the tricks
that helped them it was actually their
idea I just I just thought it was rather
funny so you can see right here the
results of this if you look at the left
these are the plane networks and we've
already sort of seen this now this is on
image net right here
you can see the 18 layer Network simply
has lower terrain and validation
accuracy so the solid line here is the
validation though on image net bold
curves denote validation error of the
center crops so I guess they do they do
sent to crop so the training error is
going to be higher because they do these
different augmentations but you can see
the training and the validation error
are higher in the deeper network if you
don't reduce residual connections again
this is not due to overfitting and if
this is because we can't train these
deep networks because we should be able
to the solution space of the 18 layer
network is a subspace of the solution
space of the 34 layer Network everything
tells us we should be able to learn the
34 layers to at least the accuracy of
the 18 layers but we can't
however introduce residual connection
Bom Bom Bom Bom and you can see that the
trend is exactly reversed now the 34
layer with residual connections has a
much much lower training and validation
error than the 18 layer in fact look at
this table right here if you introduce
the residual connections to the 18
layers it's marginally better however if
you introduce the residual connections
to the 34 layers it is a lot better and
this is another testament to the fact
that these residual connections they
really help more and more the deeper you
go you can see the effect in so this 18
layers this is sort of a vgg 19 depth
network while it and there we already
know we can train these without residual
connections right because we were able
to Train VG 19 however if we go higher
two more layers we can these residual
connections all of a sudden make it a
lot a lot better you can see that it's
not it's not that we can't train the 34
layers but the residual connections just
helped a lot more and it most of a
sudden it most of most importantly they
don't degrade the performance from the
shallower network so they they explore
the different options right here and
compare it to others different options
as I said being a B and C where a is the
zero padding for the projection B is
having projections simply between where
the channels don't fit and C being
having projections in every single
residual connection and you can see
right here that the option B gives you
quite a bit of a boost while option C
doesn't give you that much of a boost
introduces many more parameters and you
know overall is I guess they decided
against it which since then the world
has also decided against it they also do
deeper networks so they built deeper
networks
50 layer ResNet a hundred and one layer
ResNet and 152 layer ResNet and the 152
layer ResNet ended up being the best one
as you can see here and you can see a
pretty gain like it almost almost
lockstep gain depth more depth means
better network in this at the time this
these numbers they were unheard of
like even 50 layer deep neural network
was bombastic but a hundred and fifty
two layers it was as crazy and the fact
that still it has less parameters than
the vgg 19 and performs better that was
mind mind-blowing absolutely
mind-blowing and then at the end they
built an ensemble of these models and
ended up taking the 2015 image net
competition winner that was still like
very important back then it was still
very important who wins who wins image
net that year where I think I haven't
even followed up on the last few years
it's some kind of wide fix ResNet
whatnot with pre-trained and 50 billion
extra data yeah so for the deeper
networks they decide that they are
computationally rather become rather
expensive so they introduced these
bottleneck blocks here on the right
where as you can see so here if you have
a 64 dimensional input you do 64 feature
channels in your convolution have a
sixty four dimensional output you can
save computation if you first project
the higher so here you have a 256
dimensional input and they say we can
save computational power by pretty much
projecting down to 64 first because then
our complexity of this layer which is
the expensive layer will be the same as
the complexity of one of these layers
and then we can project up again the one
by one convolution they are
significantly lower computational
intensive than the 3x3 convolution
it's nine times less operations if you
think about it so that's what they use
to build the deeper residual networks
and these residual net was the ResNet
5101 152 they are still staples today
you can have these are you can have pre
trained versions of those and people
still use it like resonate 50 is used in
every segmentation what not application
so yeah this has turned out these
decisions here have you know made it
long way here you can see the number of
parameters in these residual networks
and this was the absolute craziest thing
right here 1202 layers okay so you can
see still until here ResNet 110 now this
is on C 410 right here not on image net
anymore but you can see that even 110
layers still had less parameters or
actually this select the same order of
parameters than these previous networks
that were only 19 layers deep this was
unheard of and much more unheard of 1202
layer network to train on C 410 it's a
bit of an overkill but they say their
goal was explicitly to study depth and
you can see here that with the deeper
and deeper networks they outperformed
all of the previous networks so all of
the baselines and themselves as they
went deeper and deeper and deeper
however once you go to one thousand and
two layers you go up again so here's the
question was this all just kind of a a
trick a hack and do we run into the same
problem again and that's the question
they ask themselves and the answer is no
so if you look right here so here you
see again the plane networks into plane
networks you can pretty easily see that
the more layers you have the higher your
error goes whereas in the residual
Network it's exactly the opposite way
the more layers you have the lower your
error and if you compare this 110 layer
network with the 1200 layer network you
see your validation code error going up
again however your training error and I
can't zoom in more but it's the same
it's the same and it's at zero so here
they conclude and the the here they
conclude now we are overfitting they
don't use like the biggest data
augmentation like we use today so
overfitting was still a thing back then
so now they conclude ok now we have
actually built a large enough network
that is overfitting and then and the
fact that we go up again in the training
error is due to the fact that we are
probably overfitting so not only have
they enabled us to build deeper networks
they have effectively shown that this
can get you to the to the point where
you don't need deeper networks anymore
at least on C 410 because you are
overfitting and it can effectively get
you there this is a lot of evidence for
the fact that this biasing the network's
towards the identity function is a very
valid thing to do and is the solution to
the we can't train deep networks
problems
lastly they investigate the size of the
responses so their hypothesis is that if
if it is really beneficial to bias the
network towards the identity function
and if it is really true that each of
these layers only learns a little bit
right because the identity function is
already very good each of these layers
only needs to learn kind of a small
function they look at the responses of
these things so the the response
magnitude of these layers right here of
the signal through the layers and they
compare those with the response
magnitude of the other neural net
works where you don't have the skip
connection the hypothesis is if we look
at these then the responses of these
layers should be much larger because
they have to learn much more and the
responses here will be much smaller
because the identity function is already
doing most of the work and that's
exactly what you find so here the layers
are ordered by response and you can see
the plane networks in the dashed lines
are significantly above the residual
Network even and that's not a function
of the depth because if the depth was
actually equal here you would expect
that the dashed lines would would
stretch like this they would kind of
stretch out
however exactly the opposite is
happening you can see that the residual
networks even at the beginning their
responses are very much smaller and this
is kind of what I like about this paper
it's it's one narrative it is a
hypothesis and then every single fact e
the hypothesis is taken and they make
predictions from the hypothesis they say
ok if we are right with our hypothesis
not only should our idea get us better
accuracy that's what most people most
papers do today but also you know but
also it should be that we can for
example push our network to the brink of
where we actually are overfitting like
here and it should also be that the
responses of our signal through our
layers is smaller and yeah that's
research like this is just pretty pretty
cool and it's I think a lesson for us
that sadly the world has taken the
ResNet but the world hasn't all taken
the research methodology of this paper
yeah if you again if you want a good
read it's very well written you I'm very
sure you can follow it even if you have
read very few papers and with that yeah
I hope you enjoyed this please tell me
what you think of going through kind of
old papers looking at whether or not
they have stood that
test of time and yeah any other comments
leave them in the comments I do read
them and I'll see you next time bye bye